they say all the VA needs more money I
enrages me they need more accountability
they need more cultural change they need
more competition anymore reform hi I'm
Tracy Oppenheimer fries and TV and today
we're here with concerned veterans for
America's Dan Caldwell right at the
origin of the VA scandal in Phoenix
Arizona dan thanks for having us today
well thank you for coming out and just
to start off we seem to be getting new
Intel every day from the VA problems
associated with it so if i want to just
break it down a little bit if you could
point out what we should be paying
attention to what you think the most
important problems are well everybody
needs to pay attention to scale this
it's not just an isolated incident this
is across the country at just about
every VA facility problems are starting
to emerge every major VA facility
seventy percent of VA facilities have
had somebody say that they've been
pressured to engage in inappropriate
scheduling practices so the scale of it
is astounding and Senator Coburn just
came out with his report can you talk
about some of his findings to steal a
line from order a policy analysts
basically reads like a bad movie script
about an out-of-control government
bureaucracy if a bunch of libertarians
were to get together and write a movie
script about how big government fails
and how evil it is dr. Tom Coburn wrote
it and from what you've seen in there
you have anything from you know
out-of-control VA police departments to
you know sex offenders working VA
hospitals misspent funds dr. Coburn has
really kind of put everything together
in one damning document about how bad
things are at the VA can you talk more
about the systemic problems and causes
and what what these kind of factors are
the VA as its budgets been nearly
tripled since 2001 this is not a
resource issue at the VA this is an
issue of an in a toxic culture a
management that is out of control and
thinks it's above the law and and knows
it doesn't have to do its job to get
bonuses and to keep their jobs and of a
frankly single-payer health care system
that isn't accountable to any
competition forces let's have to worry
about competitors or anything else if
you go back to late 90s what you saw
happening was as the veteran population
was starting to shrink in United States
the world war two generation was
starting to unfortunately pass away and
fewer and fewer veterans were starting
to use the VA so they made a decision
that they were going to go to Congress
there go to the president and they were
going to expand the pool of veterans
that could receive VA care by the early
2000s and by the time 911 rolled around
the war in Afghanistan began and by the
time the Iraq war began you had millions
of veterans using the VA who hadn't
qualified before that was really kind of
the start of it at the time though the
secretary of the VA secretary prince MP
made a decision to freeze enrollment for
a certain group of veterans who weren't
combat wounded that were rather well off
and that didn't have any type of service
related disabilities so for about seven
years that type of enrollment was frozen
but then secretary Shinseki comes in
President Obama comes in and that
enrollment again is opened her patient
spending increased and it has a toll top
line in increased so it wasn't like
they're getting the new the resources
not to serve these veterans the problem
was is that they seem to lack the
ability to allocate them properly and to
properly serve these veterans and make
good decisions about their care so
that's how you really kind of start to
see the development of the secret wait
lists these fudge numbers because then
at the same time you had this
performance metric system that weighed
really heavily on reducing wait times
but at the same time was very easily
gamed so you kind of this perfect storm
of you know more veterans using the
system more money not a lot of
accountability it's almost impossible to
fire and still is a VA employee who
engages in misconduct who is poorly
performing it chief of the VA and here
in Phoenix was just moved to being head
of a different part meant still at the
VA we're talking about that the chief of
staff he's a gs-15 they're very
difficult to fire and it oftentimes
takes years Sharon Helman the director
of the hospital
the secretary Shinseki supposedly one of
the last things he did will start to
process to fire july first he started at
May thirtieth she's still to our
knowledge on the payroll and you think
one of the solutions or steps towards a
solution is to start privatizing parts
of the VA can you talk about that a
little bit yes our our group and others
now believe that there should be more
services at the VA where you have a
private healthcare option particularly
primary care services you know standard
things you go to your family doctor for
whether it's a regular checkup you know
an issue with with the flu something
along those lines I I don't see a reason
why the VA should be doing those things
I think that they need to specialize in
treating for war root war wounds service
related disabilities other things along
those lines and act concerned veterans
what are you are you actively working on
these gestational problems yes we have
four really even before the scandal
broke really since our inception going
back to 2012 we've really focused a lot
at on the institutional problems in the
VA for a long time we've been supporting
a measure known as the VA management
Accountability Act which would make it
easier to fire some of these poorly
performing managers that's not part of
the the VA conference committee so we're
hopeful that in some capacity that will
be passed into law we were one of the
first groups a call for secretary
Shinseki to resign I think a lot more
people need to be resign fired in some
cases probably put in jail we think that
what you see with some of these veteran
choice act and some of these bills that
are going to give role veterans and
veterans have been on a waitlist a long
time more private health care options
probably be expanded and we'd like to
see more of that and we're going to keep
we're going to keep out there you know
pushing for the cultural change and the
legislative change as well dan thanks
thanks again for having us today thank
you for coming out and doing this story
I think it's very important
reasontv I'm Tracy Oppenheimer